do you think i will get along with your
friends you can't attack people
you come off harsh sometimes family
audiences send naked pictures
to you because they never be polite you
don't speak no more
great dinner i'll take off
natalie went and ruined mike's birthday
let me not say it like that that's a bit
harsh
she ruined the birthday dinner she threw
for mike are you just
waiting though yes i'm leaving here you
go have a good night
meanwhile mike took the party to the
house i'm gonna go home and
uh have some drinks take some shots make
the best of it
when he says home he's talking about
this house
three hours away and swim he's leaving
natalie at the hotel in seattle
which i can't help but wonder i mean is
he gonna come back and get her
how is that gonna work sounds like a
waste of trip i don't understand
well besides that one thing is clear
mike's at a point in his relationship
where his patience
is running thin so then that he is
looking for a reason to leave and if
you've been there before
you know what i mean plus i really am
left
doing everything on my own on your own
tiffany went to a lawyer to talk about
divorcing ronald
sorry i'm sorry i know it's hard and
based off her reasoning
it sounds like that might be the best
idea
sometimes i worry that i'm stuck in this
marriage
versus i'm in this marriage because i'm
happy
that's deep we're gonna talk about it
hey nanny day fans fam it's melisia
let's go ahead and jump right into mike
and natalie
in this naked picture conversation that
got him so upset
that he left his own birthday dinner
alright starting from the top
natalie found herself being romantic as
she put together a thoughtful
celebration for mike
during their trip to seattle love yes
can i please ask you to go downstairs
today's 36 pills of my husband
and since we are in seattle i thought
it's gonna be nice time to celebrate
with him
i want his day to be extra special
because ever since
i bought the ring he's been acting
really good she's just happy to see that
ring on his finger
because i doubt that this three dollar
ring she bought him last episode
from the crystal shop it's having any
effect on his behavior
whoa what do we got here baby fast
forward
mike comes downstairs and he is
impressed
what a surprise natalie secretly ordered
his favorite sushi
and grabbed a bottle of champagne you
like
it's beautiful baby oh my god was hungry
yeah it's all for your birthday love
it was wine it's something i was getting
so hungry i had no idea i should put
this together
it was awesome baby thank you so much
natalie was like
yeah i did that okay let's do
toast for you she went on to give mike a
birthday toast
and during it she admitted to being a
lot to deal with
and i'm your lovely part of you
your pain in the butt pain in the butt
yes but she also expressed her love for
him
which felt real so real that mike ended
it with an amen
i love you amen and we know his beliefs
i do not believe in religion like in a
god
i love you amen thank you so much for
this wonderful land ahead of us
ahead of us he spoke too soon
if only he knew what was ahead so are
you excited to go to your mama
yes after the toast the two started
talking about thanksgiving which was
around the corner
and natalie mentioned that she was
nervous to go to mike's mom's house
she's not that bad you know yeah she's
strong smart woman
she's also the woman who asked mike's
friend tamara to call off their wedding
i asked her if she would yes and natalie
is not
letting that go but how can i just
forgive you for that
but the talk around mike's mom isn't
what took the conversation south
things started to take a turn when
natalie told mike that she was bored and
they needed more date nights
because i'm dying from being bored she
then suggested that they take a trip to
nevada
you can play your boarding like in
snowboard where some of mike's friends
live
now at first i thought taking a trip to
nevada
was an innocent idea but
when i looked back over the episode and
i considered how everything ended
natalie knew what she was doing by
bringing up this trip
she was looking for something do you
think i will get along with your friends
i don't know that's uh depends uh on you
i guess
why because um
sometimes come off a little harsh i i
mean they have to give me a credit i'm
from another country honestly
you still got to be nice to him you
can't you can't attack people you come
off harsh sometimes i mean everyone's
like family
students send naked pictures to you
generally polite
look natalie knew she messed up look at
her eyes right here
i've had that face before i know it
it's that moment where you go too far
and you see your partner is about to get
mad for real and you're like oh my bad
my bad i feel my brain all right natalie
uh-huh
you gotta speak no more
great dinner i'll take off
mike really took the rest of his
champagne to the head
and left and he didn't just leave her at
the table
he left her in seattle
well at least that's what it looks like
uh a girl from nevada he said she is his
friend but
she kept sending him her boobs
are you really reading now yes i'm
leaving here you go
have a good night uh what is the reason
uh to stand up and leave if you have
nothing to hide
[Music]
mike i'm gonna go home
um yeah tired
[Music]
it's obviously not gonna get any better
for my birthday so i'm gonna
go home and uh have some drinks take
some shots make the best of it
so while things were going good which
natalie said they were
he's been acting really good she decided
to be sneaky
and start an entire conversation around
what she really wanted to get at
which what's the naked picture
and ask him could they please not send
you naked pictures
like i said i've been there before but
i've learned there is a time and a place
for everything
and what can really take somebody off is
you beating around the bush
when you can just be straight up about
it now on the flip side
it is kind of strange that mike got so
upset
to where he is about to drive three
hours home on the night
of his birthday that's a bit extreme
he's either really at his breaking point
with natalie
or he's not as innocent as we think
because that hit a nerve i guess we'll
find out when we get more clarity on
exactly what went down with this picture
alright let's move on to tiffany who
went to a lawyer in maryland
to get some advice about divorcing her
husband ronald
who lives in south africa but before we
get into that
i have a quick side note tiffany's story
about how she had her first child
is wild it is wild for those of you who
don't know
let me break it down when i had daniel i
was 18 years old
this is her son daniel he's adorable
such a cute kid fun fact she didn't know
she was pregnant with him
until 10 minutes before she gave birth
and i
was 18. i was a lot skinnier
and i had no belly at all and every
month i got my period
so i wasn't even thinking that could be
an option but um
yeah i got to the hospital and
one thing led to another and then i was
having a baby
so she's basically saying the dot can
lie
wow the dot can lie
i've never heard anything like that
before
daniel is a blessed child
okay back to the divorce talk
ronald and tiffany have somewhat had
issues from the very beginning
after dating for six months ronald
popped the question but two weeks later
tiffany found out that he had a gambling
addiction and
the criminal past to be his fiancee and
not
know that about him is scary you know
because you see this person that's such
an important part of your life
yet there's so much more to that person
that you don't know about
hiding something like that is red flag
number one
but hey i guess we've all missed or
ignored
a red flag before at this point it seems
like ronald's got a grip on the
addiction
and they share a one-year-old daughter
named carly together
but now red flags 2 3 4 5 and 6 are just
flying all over the place because
tiffany revealed that ronald
has not been supporting his daughter
kovid has
really put my marriage through the
ringer
the last time ronald and i were
physically together was
eight months ago ronald right now is
not emotionally supportive he's not
financially supportive
not once does ronald offer hey let me
buy diapers for carly
hey let me send her some clothes let me
send you money for clothes nothing
and that's so frustrating because it's
not only my responsibility
i didn't make this baby alone first of
all shout out to all of the moms out
there
who are unfortunately doing it alone or
who have had to do it alone
but you made it happen or you are making
it happen
i know it may not feel like it sometimes
but trust and believe your efforts
are not in vain as tiffany started to
discuss her situation with the lawyer
she got emotional at certain points i'm
handling a lot on my own
but it seems like everything boiled down
to the fact that if the spousal visa
they applied for
which will allow ronald to come to the
states goes through
tiffany thinks that this situation which
is already
bad will get even worse dealing with it
in two separate countries is hard what
if he's the same way when he's here
yeah then i'm just gonna have to be
miserable every day feels so like
unaccepted
because she's still on the fence about
divorce and ronald has no clue that this
is even a conversation
the lawyer ended up giving her some
really sound advice
at the end of the day what you really
need to figure out is
am i better off with him or am i better
off without him
you'll know when when it's time because
to get to the point where you say i'm
better off without him
then you'll you'll you'll be ready to go
through the process
they say when you know you know i guess
that goes for divorce too
all right well next week based off of
the preview tiffany is inching her way
closer and closer to that moment of
clarity
in my mind all i can imagine right now
is ronald's coming to america
and it's all gonna be on me i honestly
think that she
can be her best happy by herself not
really with
ronald all right 90 day fans fam
so make sure you stay updated on all the
latest news coming out the 90 day
universe
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i will see you next time
you